Esta vez hablaremos de pirámides, pero no sólo
de las pirámides de Keops, de Chichén Itzá o de
Intihuatana, en Machu Picchu, sino de todas las
pirámides vistas como figuras geométricas. En
estos videos aprenderemos a calcular su volumen,
el área de sus caras y otras cosas ingeniosas,
como la fórmula de Euler que relaciona sus caras,
aristas y vértices. Podemos definir una pirámide
como un poliedro. Recordemos que un poliedro
es una figura en tres dimensiones, donde todas
las caras son planas y todas las aristas son
rectas. Entonces, una pirámide es un poliedro,
donde una de sus caras es una región poligonal
llamada base y las otras caras son regiones
triangulares con un vértice en común. Pero, ¿qué
diferencias hay entre una pirámide y un prisma?
Los prismas también son poliedros, sólo que ellos
tienen dos caras paralelas que son polígonos y se
llaman bases, mientras que el resto de las caras
son paralelogramos y son las caras laterales.
Ahora bien, si es una pirámide regular, es decir,
si la base es un polígono regular y las caras
laterales triángulos isósceles, entonces su nombre
lo define el polígono que forma su base. Por
ejemplo, esta es una pirámide triangular, esta es
una pirámide cuadrangular y esta es una pirámide
pentagonal. Ahora bien, una pirámide consta de
una base, caras laterales, aristas y vértices.
Aquí tenemos una pirámide cuadrangular, es decir,
su base es un cuadrado de lado "L", y vamos a
decir que su altura es la mitad de la longitud
de ese lado, es decir, 1/2 de "L". Ahora bien,
si construimos un cubo cuyo lado es "L" y metemos
dentro de él nuestra pirámide cuadrangular,
observa que la base coincide exactamente con la
base del cuadrado, pero -recuerda- que su altura
es 1/2 de "L", por lo tanto, podemos observar
que el cubo puede contener seis pirámides,
cada una de ellas tiene como base una cara y todas
convergen en el centro del cubo, como muestra el
siguiente dibujo. Entonces, vamos a escribir
que tenemos 6 pirámides. Si sabemos que el
volumen de todo el cubo es "L" al cubo, y también
sabemos que el área de la base es "L" cuadrada
y que la altura de nuestra pirámide es 1/2
de "L", entonces, como tenemos 6 pirámides,
el volumen de cada pirámide es 1/6 de "L" al
cubo, ¿cierto? Pero 1/6 de "L" al cubo es lo
mismo que 1/3 de "L" cuadrada • 1/2 de "L", es
decir, es lo mismo que 1/3 • el área de la base •
la altura de la pirámide. ¡O sorpresa! Después
de manipular un poco estos datos obtenemos esta
expresión que sirve de fórmula para calcular el
volumen de la pirámide. El volumen es igual a 1/3
• el área de la base • la altura de la pirámide.
Aquí "Ab" es el área de la base y "h" es la altura
de la pirámide. Muy bien. ¡Qué emoción! Así
que hagamos ahora este ejemplo. Si tenemos una
pirámide cuadrangular, y sabemos que uno de los
lados de la base mide 10 centímetros y la altura
de la pirámide es de 15 centímetros, entonces
podemos decir que el volumen de la pirámide es...
Pausa el video e inténtalo. Muy bien, utilicemos
la fórmula. El volumen va a ser igual a 1/3 • el
área de la base • la altura, así que primero
calculemos el área de la base. Como sabemos
que es un cuadrado, su área es lado por lado,
o lado al cuadrado, lo que es 10 centímetros,
esto elevado al cuadrado, o 100 centímetros
cuadrados, entonces el volumen será: 1/3 por
100 centímetros cuadrados por 15 centímetros,
lo que es... bueno: 15 / 3 = 5, 5 • 100 = 500,
500 centímetros cúbicos. Y ya está, tenemos
nuestro volumen. Bien, veamos otro ejemplo.
Esta vez tenemos una pirámide pentagonal. Sabemos
que uno de los lados de su base mide 6 metros,
el apotema de la base mide 4 metros y tiene una
altura de 12 metros. Pausa el video e inténtalo.
Primero calculemos el área de la base.
Si recordamos el área de un pentágono es:
perímetro • apotema / 2, es decir, el perímetro
es 5 veces el lado, entonces son 30 metros • 4
metros de apotema nos da 120 metros cuadrados / 2
es 60 metros cuadrados; ésa es el área de la base.
Ahora, al sustituir los valores en la fórmula
del volumen, tenemos que el volumen es igual a un
tercio por el área de la base, que son 60 metros
cuadrados, por la altura, que son 12 metros, eso
nos da 60 / 3 = 20 metros cuadrados • 12 metros
= 240 metros cúbicos. Y hemos acabado. Muy bien,
qué interesante. Hicimos una construcción que nos
permitió aprender a calcular el volumen de las
pirámides. ¡Sensacional! ¿Pero podemos descubrir
más secretos o propiedades de las pirámides?
Te invito a reflexionar en esto. Y aprovecho para
compartir contigo un resultado del gran matemático
Euler que relaciona las caras, vértices y aristas
de una pirámide. Euler propuso que, en una
pirámide, la suma de las caras más los vértices
es igual a la suma de las aristas de la pirámide
más 2. Vamos a verlo en esta pirámide. Tenemos una
pirámide cuadrangular con, bueno, son cinco caras:
la base y los cuatro triángulos laterales, 5
caras; y vemos que tiene 5 vértices: las esquinas
de la base y el vértice de arriba; por último,
vamos a contar las aristas: tenemos 8, cuatro en
la base y cuatro en las caras laterales. Entonces,
utilizando la propuesta de Euler, las caras más
los vértices, es decir 5 + 5, debe de ser igual
a las aristas más dos, es decir 8 + 2, lo cual
es 10. Perfecto, funciona. Esta fórmula funciona
muy bien y le llamamos el Teorema de Euler. Este
teorema puede ser útil de varias maneras, así
que hagamos este otro ejercicio. En esta nueva
situación tenemos 10 aristas y 6 vértices, ahora
queremos saber de qué pirámide se trata a partir
de esta información. ¿Podremos saberlo? Pausa el
video e inténtalo. Bueno, usemos el Teorema de
Euler. Las caras más los vértices es igual a las
aristas más 2; sustituyendo los valores tenemos
que "C", que es nuestra incógnita, más la cantidad
de vértices, que en este caso son 6, es igual al
número de aristas que son 10 más 2, entonces C =
10 + 2 - 6, y esto es igual a 6, entonces, tenemos
6 caras. ¿De qué tipo de pirámide se trata? Bueno,
tal vez estés tentado a decir "De una pirámide
hexagonal", pero piénsalo un poco, necesitamos
una base, ¿cierto?, entonces tenemos una base
y 5 triángulos laterales, es decir, una pirámide
pentagonal. Y lo grandioso del Teorema de Euler es
que funciona para cualquier poliedro. Por ahora,
aquí me despido. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.